Welcome to all of you.
Welcome to the math circle which is
extremely peculiar because we never teach
anyone anything.
It's a school without lectures,
without textbooks,
without grades,
without tests,
without homework.
What does it have left math and the
beauty of it and collegial conversation.
Never competitive people.
A very small group of people.
Always 10 is about our
maximum with a leader.
All the leader does is put accessible
mystery in front of them and accessible
mystery something which really leads
behind the appearances to the underlying
structure.
Our book,
the art of the infinite has
10 of those mysteries in it.
Hidden structure which it
takes a lot of imagination,
goodwill conversation with
one another to uncover,
to come to grips with and still have
doubts at the end but informed doubts.
Our motto,
well,
one of them is learning to
speak our loss native language,
but another is tell me that I forget asked
me and I discover and not only do the
students in the master goal to teach
one another and the what that hidden
structure is in their discoveries,
but they come to admire
one another and have self,
their own self esteem increased
because they're not being told things,
they're discovering them.
But look, what am I doing?
I'm telling you things
because this is wrong.
You should be discovering for
yourself with a math circle is.
So let's give you a demonstration.
Let's guys,
here's the question.
I'm going to draw a,
a grid of five by five grid.
By grid I mean kind of a chess board.
Um,
five lines.
We'll have five spaces for squares.
You don't want me for,
this is weird.
I need six lines to get
five horizontal spaces.
So I guess I'm going to need six.
Yes.
Vertical lines to get,
how many squares do I have?
Are you sure? Yes. Okay. No,
I'll take your word for it.
One, two, three, four,
five. That might be.
I was counting I, I didn't
hear him. He say one.
You're sure
you have a very orderly mind.
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine,
10 1112 1314 51617181920
oh, I forgot. Sorry. I'll
take your word for it.
They're 25
wonderful idea.
Okay.
I'm gonna learn a lot from you guys.
If you were to start in
the upper left and square,
do I have that right? Okay. Thank you.
If you were to start there and draw a
line that's going to go through all the
squares each square once and only once,
and never take your chore off the Board
or your pen off the paper even when to
go up and down and left and right.
Okay.
Is it possible to do that starting
from here or probably not possible?
Yes. I think. What do, what do you
think? You think it's possible?
I don't think so. Yep. Come on, Joey.
Oh,
fantastic.
Okay. I'm convinced. Thank you.
That's, that's great idea. Thank you.
Do you agree that's the only way
you can do that? That's terrific.
Samuel, you, it could come and Shelby.
Okay. All Yours Samuel. Oh,
oh, that's neat. And I forget
if we can get to the, Oh,
you've got to the middle of one.
Terrific. Terrific. Thank you very much.
So there are two ways of
doing it. Yes. Petra, come on.
Really?
You're saying there's a third way?
Yes.
Oh,
you're doing it kind
of in the rotated way.
It's [inaudible] kind of
rotated 90 degrees. Beautiful.
There are three there. Wait
a minute. Daniel. Daniel,
how many ways are there going to be
over a hundred over a hundred.
Nathan, did you calculate this or
no? I'm sorry. I should've
said can't go diagonally.
Only up and down and left and right.
It was a brilliant idea.
I liked diagonal lines as a
lot of, you know, but not here.
And we've asked this one and then covered
that and then cover that and then do
it like that.
Show me Daniel without the dad.
She'd go diagonally down.
You stops here and then you and then you
go up and then when my dad and then you
can do that with the out using a
diagonal with an up and down motion
down all the way
up,
all the way
you want. You want to connect that
back up there. Oh, that's nice.
You've got to kind of a
revelation of a castle.
One, two, three, four, five. I
think. One, two, three, four,
five, one, two, three,
four, five. You were right.
This is an extra box of mine.
Okay. Then go ahead. Go ahead.
Go ahead.
Wait, wait. You had a good question.
They have to have to conduct
definitely one continuous line.
I think this is really nice.
Daniel does his work
as a hundred you say forever,
which is more or less forever a deal.
Fantastic. Hold onto it. Okay,
Daniel, this is great. Thanks a lot.
I remember where you were ever
getting news. How about usher?
Petra.
Petra?
I'm not sure it's the question.
It's,
it's one of the questions that that I
thought of and you've got to come up with
fantastic
answers. One, two no, three no four,
no, 100, no one infinite number.
Oh, sure. And then
while I'm doing this thing for yourself,
decide the question of
how many ways are there,
we know there were at least three or
four and there might be a hundred.
There might be an infant room. Yeah,
there's not an infinite number.
Why not? Because like eventually
you're going to actually,
you have to have an infinite number of
boxes to have an infinite number of what
a great idea.
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five, one, two,
three, four, five. Okay.
Oh,
this is like Danielle's.
Oh Yup.
Patrol is telling him something.
I don't think the chocolates make lesions.
Oh,
that's great.
Oh, sure did. Was to
combine previous ideas.
That's doing math.
That's taking previous,
I promise I'll come to you
later immediately. Uh, taking,
building on these ideas together.
You're working collegially
it's just super with uh,
kind of top of a castle.
You see those Tufts up a castle and then
some of the straight line right down
the middle.
Could it have been elsewhere
and then zip over and do the
zigzag backward. It's really nice.
By the way, your your letter,
he is hiding in here. Okay. Um, Leah,
different from all
these, okay. Come on up.
Maybe there really are an infinite number.
Think about another question.
Besides how many ways,
sorry.
When do you accidentally going to copy
one of the ones that you are such a good
question.
Is anyone keeping track of whether we're
going to be doing something again that
we did before or you rememory so good.
Mine isn't that.
You'll remember all the previous
ones. Very good point. Um,
or are you worried that
yours might be an old one?
Okay.
If you're pretty sure not,
that means it must be a different,
a different basic idea.
I'm actually kind of
surprised nobody did it. Okay.
It shows that although we all have
mines and they're all terrific,
our minds work differently.
Oh,
oh,
stop for a second. Does anybody
worried? Yeah. You're worried.
Yeah. You're worried. Okay.
Step aside for a second.
Don't, don't say why you're worried, but
you're both worried. Anybody else worried?
You're worried?
Go ahead.
Oh,
I actually,
oh,
you're really seeing things.
You're seeing things that don't work.
Which kind of tells you what does work.
Go ahead.
Oh, excellent. You avoided the
problem of having two directions.
You had to go in and you could
want to go in one. Beautiful.
I do think that's new, isn't
it? Yeah. Okay. That is super.
You guys are amazing. You idea
having other ones. Okay. Come on up.
Can I leave this and give
you a pink shawl? Okay.
Oh,
that's a nice,
that's really nice.
Looking at this,
looking at the pink one at pink one,
can you automatically see another one that
hasn't been done automatically? Great.
Leah? I think I do. Don't
come up and tell me.
Looking at the pink mine, do
you automatically, let me,
let me recite the pink line.
Start here.
Go right all the way. Go down all
the way. Go across all the way.
Go up part of the way up to the fourth
square and then start wiggling down and
stop there.
Yes,
Nathan minds,
but I think you'll have to.
Okay.
Yes.
So you took part of what
you did and changed it.
Nice idea. Wait, actually, no,
we shouldn't be there. I know.
Losing track of whether
repeating anything's we had.
One of the things we had
before. That's, that's terrific.
You guys have an enormous
amount of imagination because
math is done with one's
imagination. Let me ask you a
question before you pick up your,
you're basically running this class,
not me, but I have, I've got a question.
I'm going to take one of the paths.
I know it was done. If
fact, the very first one,
I want you to tell me something.
Here's that first path.
I forget where the
like that. Am I right? Yeah. Okay.
Without doing anything,
without asking me to do anything more.
Tell me a second path
that's there. Yes. Yes.
It's the same phone
start to finish.
Is it a star finish?
Every time you draw one path
you get one more for free.
That means whether the
number is 200 or infinite.
It's going to have to be even because
for every path you draw there's the path
with the end of the beginning of reversed.
So weird.
Well that's, there are at least
two paths. There are at least four.
I mean there are at least six.
I mean,
what do I mean there are at least
a hundred there might be 99 yes,
we had five and then it gets
the point you made Talton yeah.
Yup.
Good.
Myself,
I got a different sort of a question.
This is work so well and we haven't
even began to finally settle on how many
times you can do it.
Starting here is there,
this is a weird question.
Is there any other place you could have
started that would have worked at all or
as well?
Leah.
Okay,
star here.
How do you know about is going to work?
Well,
you can just go the opposite way.
Terrific possible start possible start.
Petra
starts in the sector.
Hey, that's wonderful. We had a
path that ended in the setter.
Therefore there has to be a path
that starts from the center. Asher,
so ending up what she said.
All right.
That you could start on
the top right corner.
You could actually get old
ones we've currently done.
You could just turn them right,
rotate the board instead of
rotating our drawing deal.
What were you gonna say?
Any part on the boy would
be a possible solution,
but you just have to alter the wrong.
Fantastic. You could start
in any square so far.
We know you can start
then this one and this one
and this one and this one and
in the center or in this one?
This one. In this one and this
one or there. I'm just doing the,
taking the endings and going
back to the beginnings.
I seem to have gotten the same thing.
There are at least five places you can
start from and your suggestion is we
could start absolutely anywhere
and just be careful. Okay.
I want to take what you suggested.
Dhea,
you feel pretty much in charge of
this question right now? Yeah, Nathan,
so I was wondering, can I
show? Yeah, yeah. Come on up.
Okay.
What an interesting idea.
Could you go like
you lifted your truck,
you can't lift your truck.
Nevertheless,
you can do what you wanted I think
without lifting your truck here, let me,
let me just,
I mean you could,
I was just wondering if you could use
to start going and push it off two ways.
Your question is, can you for,
I could do it without lifting.
Go ahead.
Oh,
watch out for this guy.
Okay.
I'll be much more precise.
You're asking me to be more precise in
my language without lifting your chalk
and without going over the
same line the second time.
Only once. Wait a minute.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
I've just drawn that line.
7,981 times,
haven't I?
They're all next to one another.
I think Nathan, you could
still get your pattern. Do it.
Oh yeah, right to question.
If you could go two ways.
Gotcha. That's a really nice other
question which we should explore.
Nathan's brought up completely new
question. Take a five by five grid or,
or of four, two by two
grid aren't. They're
twofold. Double paths that'll
work and if so, how many?
In other words instead of going like that.
Could you go like that and then
like that where something like that.
Interesting question. Yes. Daniel.
Or if you have two arms, cause you have
to have two hands for the piece of,
if you're an octopus you can do eight,
right?
You can also program a
robot to like three or nine.
Very good.
I want to get back to something to do.
You're raised going back to
our original, um, whoops.
Our original five by five.
Do you said, tell me if I'm,
if I'm quoting you correctly,
do they really,
you can start from any square as
long as you're careful. Right.
But any place that's
like next to the corner,
you can't start there.
A fascinating idea. Let's see. Let's see,
one, two, three, four, five. I'll, I'll
try to be really careful in drawing this.
You were saying starting in
a place next to a corner,
where would you like me to start from?
By the way?
Somebody suggested at the very beginning
that we do something which would make
talking about this sport.
Remember what it was,
what I was counting the squares where
I was counting all 25 of them and I was
counting this way and that
we'll say it again.
Yes.
What should go in rows.
There was something besides my
finger that somebody suggested I do.
You played mark every square.
You've already,
she wouldn't double count,
but you could still do that.
What do you want to market with?
I was thinking how sure of your question
about is this all going to be geometry?
It could be something else.
Well, it's not geometry, but
like, I mean I met like, Hey,
what do you mean equation math? Go on.
What do we equations involve numbers.
What if I mark these scores with numbers?
Somebody said at the beginning,
why don't you just number the squares?
I like it takes longer,
but you could actually,
I was thinking when I said that
more about speed and not really.
I know, I know, but I think
you can count by fives.
You can count by fives.
I'm good at it.
Last time.
What I did was I counted in this way,
but I could really be very regular and
count like this if I put these numbers in
just to make it easier to talk about
when Dhea suggested I start in a square
next to a square in the corner.
I guess she meant square number two.
Oh,
thanks for filling this in.
21222320420
five okay.
Couldn't stay there because this way
is this going to work?
I can show you how you can do.
That's great to hear.
Thank you.
Except when you go here you go.
Go like this.
Well actually no, not that this
is wrong.
Things to use Roy,
that you can't start from square
number two Asher and then Daniel. Oh,
you all got your hands up at once
then Daniel, then Samuel. Yes.
You could
watch
that actually on the board.
It's looking at
what is going on with the
problem that Diaz raised.
Takes it over here.
She can't make it easier by cause
he doesn't have to go like that.
He can do it here. Let's see.
So are you saying two, one, six,
seven, eight three, four, five, ten nine.
So far so good.
14 1520 and then you go to
20,025 I don't draw that.
And blue,
go ahead.
This is going to work.
She's retracing the previous path,
but when she gets to 20,
she goes down to 25 across to 24
after 20 91823221716 and skipped 13.
Yes. Wait, Atlanta,
another way that's going to
work starting with two. Great.
And Samuel, you've had your hand
up for a long time starting.
Maybe you could go
now what? You've left out 15. Oh, right,
yes.
Can you put the same line and two squares?
What do you mean?
Like if there was one square,
could you put two lines in there?
Oh, no, nope. Absolutely not. Um,
what the mind is a straight,
steady line and it never goes back in
the square in a square. It's been in,
uh,
what does it mean?
How AQAP during down a deer
could just spiral.
Let's try a spiral.
Go on. Go ahead. Go ahead.
Oh,
yeah. Yeah. We ended 19. Yep.
Stuck again.
Is this something wrong with our
imaginations or with the problem?
Uh, Leah. Terrific.
At Dia you think you have one?
How about Dhea than Leah
asked herself what is going on?
It was so successful starting from corner
with lots and lots of an even number
of paths and we can't even get one
starting from square two started.
Well we can get it started but he
can't go on one, two, three, four,
five, one, two, three,
four,
five and we're starting to,
this is going to be responsible.
It was beautiful up to there.
What is wrong? Why can't we
do this? You guys are so good.
Yes.
It's kind of wedged in between two pieces.
Pieces wedged in between two pieces.
Is that what you mean?
Well except one piece hasn't
got you
your idea. Come on. This is great.
This is really fascinating.
Trouble we're having.
I don't quite understand why we're
having so much trouble with it.
I mean you guys now all that
you're really good at this.
You're good at imagining counting.
You're actually better I think
at than I am and yet just saying,
can we start in the second
square from the quarter?
Well,
prior to tribe.
So far so good.
Oh, thank you. Oh wait a sec. One,
two, three, four, five.
It's that stops here.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Stop for a second.
Is it okay so far?
Any trouble?
Do you see any trouble in the
future? You see trouble, Samuel?
Where do you see trouble?
Ah Ha. Okay, go ahead.
So far she's avoiding that.
The look what's happened.
Look what's happened.
You have a choice.
If they've then,
if Nathan's idea that we could go in
two directions at once, we'd be done,
but we don't have that.
We can only go in one direction at
once and you can either go up and you
certainly are welcome to go up,
but then you leave that out.
You can go left and he felt that way.
Why is it so difficult?
Why doesn't it work?
What's the trouble with
us? Yes. Fantastic.
Come on up.
Okay.
That,
that the old top of the castle.
Wait, wait, wait. This just
six. Sarah and Sarah. I'll
just, I'll just get rid of, uh,
that much.
Okay.
You mean there's already trouble? It's
too late already. Leah, what do you think?
Too late already
then.
I think your idea was great.
Yes.
Let's see
what's happened here. Oh,
this is okay. In other words,
you've missed that square. How did I
know that there was going to be a problem
that's called induction.
Gone Away.
Oh dear.
Why don't you all say the minute
you see a problem coming up?
We start here. Anybody see
a problem coming up? Okay.
Okay. So far. Okay.
Okay, so far. Why is it okay so far?
Yeah, to say an idea. Okay.
We know what she's the one who
got one choice when she's here,
she has to go this way and you choose to
go all the way across everything. Okay.
So far
it's meant to be five by five by five.
Oh,
okay.
Keep that idea in mind. Yes. Sasha.
Wait, wait, wait, let go ahead. Go ahead.
Go ahead with what you've got
ups,
you got in the square twice.
Uh, you can't, you went
and squares twice again.
You want to because you want to get to
that square and that's the only way you
can do it and you're stuck.
You're just one square off finishing it.
It's interesting. And one,
two, three, four, five, one,
two years is five by five
and you've done that.
You
should. We number her
steps. This is one, two,
three, four, five,
six. I'm sorry. We don't we,
well that's because I started
with a number two in the corner.
There still is five squares. I'm numbering
now the steps instead of the roads. Uh,
seven, eight, nine,
01112131415 1516
1718 61718192021
to 23.
I'm not sure we're ever going to
get to that. Where would a second
one, two, three, four, five,
one, two, three, four. Oh, sorry.
My board seems to have one, two, three,
four, five. Yeah, six. It's six wide.
That's interesting. When it was
66 wide, it's broken by one.
Oh, right. You are
right. You are one, two,
three, four, five. That
line going through is that,
it's to the point that one square,
how's this worked?
I might take,
take a look at d as paper.
So far so good by the way.
One, two, three, four,
five by one, two, three, four.
One, two, three, four.
Wait a sec. Oh, oh, I see. Those are
two. One, two, three, four, five.
One, two, three, four,
five. Okay, so you go
down the left hand side
and across the bottom.
Up the right. Oh, you've
gone into this square twice
with this line and with that line.
Oh, it was so beautiful off to there.
Oh, 10 minutes left. How can this be?
Can we do this for another two hours
please? There we asked you what?
Yes. Daniel says yes. 10
more door hours. Okay.
Is it going to work when you start from
the second square? Hi Nathan. What?
I can I show you some? Oh wait,
I might do it on the board. Yep,
please join.
Racist words I think are awesome.
It's basic.
It's kind of the same as this,
but I think our phones
out we been going across.
It does.
Well,
I didn't,
I didn't realize so I was just estimating
that that might be the problem because
I like to estimate some things,
but why luxury estimate of a
hundred is a while ago, by the way,
after you asked a long time ago,
is this going to be geometry?
This might be arithmetic
instead of geometry.
I don't know. Asher and then Petra, I
don't think this really counts though.
So like,
oh,
ah,
yeah.
So far that is backward.
If something that I think dia did
now zigzagging,
stop. You'll, you'll
never get into the list.
Oh yeah, yeah, exactly.
Great.
I've got it for us. Funny question
to ask him for Petra and Leah,
how big is this board? I squares by
five squares. Namely how many squares?
Right squared? Five squared. True.
What is five squared is 25 it's 25
what kind of a number is 25 it's a
square number on the smaller number.
It's an odd number.
Squared. It's an odd number.
Can I go back to Nathan's to buy
to board to board to was what?
What's two times two? This is very
difficult. I know, but more or less for,
I mean you estimate so it's kind of four
and Alec to by two board a board with
four squares. Can we start
from here? Will it work?
Can we start it from here?
Here, here? Yes. Uh Huh.
The two by two works is that there's no
square in the middle of the two corner
pieces or a credit piece.
Wow.
What a three by three so a three
by three would or wouldn't work.
Three lines.
Three there is that Middle Square.
Oh,
three by three is trouble.
Five by five is trouble.
What's 729 by 729 trouble
or easy? Actually, I got it.
I did it from, Oh actually, no I didn't.
I did it because I sent
him the frame here. Oh,
you started from the first
square? No. Yes. Oh, he's
worth from the second squared.
This, this piece of Jack got, oh
wait, actually no. Yep. Right.
Starting from the second square.
Hold on.
Odd Number Board does
it not work is trouble.
Why Petra?
There probably is a way to do it twice.
It's hard to find.
That's great. It, there's
probably a way to do it,
but it's hard to find that
after you were saying,
there's just no way to fight it no
matter how you try five whole minutes.
Oh, say it Osher. So I'm just gonna draw
a three by three. Okay, good.
So if you start from here,
you can't really do anything
about it because there's, uh,
there's always going to be this extra
corner and if you try to eliminate that
corner, I don't know, middle
pieces is not going to work. See,
so here you won't work
because you have to,
once you get to like when you to the
point where it's either a corner or the
center, you're always going
to get there. You have to,
you have to only go to one.
It's going to leave the center
out or one of the corners.
Okay.
Is a 6.6 board go to work or not?
It will because it's a seven by seven.
No dear.
That's terrific.
Any even number by even number,
then it's going to work because like
the reason sales where there's no
middle,
Middle Square,
it won't cross that one odd square.
Yeah,
that one. What? Square square?
That one odd square on a 25 square board.
Five by five.
How many odd number squares are there
and how many even number of squares?
Yes, I'd prefer square since
it starts with an odd number,
there's going to be one more.
There's always one more odd number square
then even on an odd number of board
and on an even number board.
Okay. Yes, Leah? Five by five. It's not,
it's kind of weird but,
but I think,
I think you're onto the hidden
deep structure of this problem.
There's always an extra odd number
square on an odd number board and if you
going to cover every square, you
better start for them. Odd One.
We are not going to cover them all because
there's an extra odd one somewhere in
the center or in a corner
or something like that.
The number on an odd number of squares.
Fantastic guys. Leo,
what do you want to say?
At the end of this, are we able
to ask him a bunch of questions?
Please do. I'm not going to have
any answers, but go ahead and ask.
Okay.
Oh, those are the books
that Ellen and I wrote.
The first one out of the
labyrinth is about this approach,
the mass circle approach,
where we do math in the real way.
If you guys doing the thinking
so you own it, it's yours.
This is the way we invented with
no textbooks, no tests, no quizzes,
no being told,
but asked and people working together
the way you all did fantastically to come
to the deep, hidden, underlying
structure of the world. The other book,
the art of the infant,
which is mathematics because mathematics
is almost always about the infinite,
the infinite number of possibilities.
It has 10 different problems in it
like this one which is lead you from
confusion and chaos on the
surface to deep structure.
That makes sense.
That gives meaning to a whole thing.
These are the people to afford.
We have 20 minutes.
Fuck. Question. Answer.
Okay. How about parents?
Parents Bedroom.
If you end on square,
you can do it backwards and
it will be the same lines.
Absolutely. Absolutely. That's right.
Start on one end on 25 in one of our
patterns store on 25 and on one in the
paired pattern.
Asher.
Hi. Actually, I
like what the art basically
by my name. Matt. Hi.
Actually,
I'm pretty sure infinity is not a number.
You're right. It's like big and
small. Infinity is not a number,
but it is an idea we have. About
how many, oh actually I'm sorry,
how many counting numbers are there?
MMM,
well I thought there were 10,981
counting numbers.
I thought they ended up,
I thought the last one was 10,981
so anytime I name accounting
number you can say,
well there's one more and that must
suggest there are not a finite,
not an ended number of them.
So the infinite is hiding behind this.
How many boards those this problem work
on for any possible starting place and
infinite number,
all the even number boards.
And there are an infinite
number of even numbers.
Any questions along the Sterns? Yes. Yeah.
How are we going to do
something like this again? Oh,
you mean in the master circle?
Yeah,
like a maybe something since you've
already seen this. Only beyond this.
Yeah. Maybe. Maybe. Maybe
I have a question. Oh yes,
yes. Go ahead. In this setting,
the beginning was just a, you
know, drawing, so everybody
started on the same page.
What happens when you need to use more
mathematical notation or machinery?
The people in the class may have different
levels of comfort with coming in to
the circle.
The kid should invent the notation
and the symbols themselves.
Why use the inherited old
fashioned clouded symbols?
Make your own all the daf to them.
The world will adapt to them.
If you don't like writing fractions
this way.
Right? Some that way or
that way or any way you choose as
long as you explain what you mean.
You mean that many of
those kinds of things,
that many of those kinds of things.
11 of the seventeens.
Whereas this
would mean 17 of the 11 kind of things.
The numerator, it tells you the number.
The denominator tells you
what the denomination, the
name. So I have a question.
Um hmm.
One of the things that eventually
happened was we switched from can you be a
challenge of
many of us in the audience heard, can you
start from the second square as being,
are you clever enough to come up with a
way to start from the second square and
you know,
the process led to finally having to ask,
can you be, can anyone,
is it possible? I'm
curious whether that is
having done this many times.
Do you,
do you see that that is often a crux
that these things turn on and it was
a crux on which the math
circle turns a fulcrum,
a widget balances,
self confidence and lack of it.
One comes in as a human enter this
world and after just a little bit of
experience loses one's nerve.
And so if it cannot be done this because
I can't do it until you begin to say,
well, maybe, maybe nobody can do it.
A great British biologist,
WBS Haldane in the 1930 he said,
it may not be that the universe
is stranger than we think.
It may be that it's stranger
than we can think. Well,
what if this problem?
What if it turned out we hadn't come
up with a solution and we came to the
conclusion that, well, we've hit
the boundaries of human ability.
We hit the limit of our ability
as you gain and self confidence,
you say, listen, the world's
my oyster. I control this.
Mathematics is made by humans for humans.
If we can come off with a problem,
we can answer it. Now, for those of you
who know some history of mathematics,
you know that what I've just said is
a complete lie because in 1915 good,
all of Austrian logician proved that there
are questions you can state and state
very clearly and very well,
which you will never be able to answer,
which is devastating.
Now,
the answer to good will is not.
Oh yeah.
But with mathematics as it's presently
understood with set theory as it's
presently understood,
that is a limitation.
But maybe the trouble is with set theory,
maybe the trouble is with the
way we're posing the problem,
maybe we just don't have our understanding
of those relations deep enough.
Imagined enough yet.
Why shouldn't anything be our oyster?
There was a mathematician in the 17th
century and Italian than Vhr who said,
Nola gone problem. I saw Solaray there
is no problem that can't be solved.
And so Sinai,
let me leave you all with a problem.
This is not the end of the conversation,
but let me just leave
you with this problem,
all of you and email me
when you have some ideas.
How many corners does a
10 dimensional cube have?
Think about that. Send me an
answer. Three part question. Good.
Ah,
first part is, are you
thoroughly convinced that, uh,
the problem of starting the path on the
second square is impossible for all odd
by odd squares and possible for all,
even by even squares.
Are you asking if I'm convinced I math,
I might be asking the,
the uh,
rest of the class.
But um,
they shouldn't be because we did in 40,
50, 50 minutes. What's
deep complex problem.
And we haven't talked about induction
if that's what's on your mind. Yeah,
pretty much. Exactly. Once,
and this brings up an answer to a question
someone else asked when I guess it a
tall, when the symbolism, when
the concepts become deeper,
when we come to grips with induction,
which we could do in 20 minutes,
we can re ask that question,
can you generalize even dimensional boards
and how can you know that a 10,984 by
10,984 board and you can
start from anywhere on,
I mean it'd be really nice to
say, listen, piece of cake,
Yo meal.
This is just a pretty practical question,
a very interesting question,
but I was curious as to why you decided
to start with a five by five grid
instead of this three by three grid.
Uh,
cause it seems like maybe some of the
conclusions that kids would have come up
to might've been a little bit
faster given the time constraints.
So I was wondering if there's a creativity
saying or like an exercise or I guess
what led to that decision?
Really good question.
I started with something which I
knew was going to be beautiful,
easy a piece of cake and we'd
all be tremendously confident,
confident enough to look at a hard
aspect of it that hadn't been thought of.
Stuart will it one by one and they
would have run out of the room saying,
what are you doing?
And we of course you start in the middle
of a one by one and end with, yeah, okay.
Or if I'd said 10 million by 10 million,
they were,
I can't think in those terms.
Five by five sounds comfortable.
It turns out that the springs in that
armchair or broken and you have to,
you feel uneasy and you get more and
more uneasy in it until it turns out,
oh, I know how to repair those
springs. I understand how it works,
but you need an accessible mystery.
It's got to be appealing.
It's thought to be mysterious.
We were asked to do a math circle in a
prison and we said, Oh, love to do that.
We'll, we'll do it next year.
And they said, no, do it
next week. And he it. Well,
we're very busy next, but you're
doing it Wednesdays. All right,
so Ellen and I went home and thought
on God, what are we going to do? Well,
we'll make sure our wills are in order.
And we were worked out a
routine having the prison.
It was a high security prison.
If you've ever been inside or visiting,
it's very frightening.
The guards are much more
frightening than the prisoners.
All your belongings are taken away from.
You would put in a drawer and there's
barbed wire on top of the walls. Anyway,
we were put in a room and our guides left
and the room was small and the people
were big.
They spend their time bodybuilding.
There were a 17 I counted of them and
there were two of us up against the
blackboard. They fill the floor. They
were sitting on the floor and we said,
this is the routine we'd worked
out. I said, math, it's awful,
isn't it? Right on. They said,
Ellen said, yeah, you know,
they ask you stupid questions like
what's one plus two? We fell silent,
somebody says three, what do you take
us for? It's all of course it's three.
And then that day I said your,
they ask them what's one plus two plus
three and voice over there six and then
came words, which I will not
repeat it from the audience.
And while I'm saying this,
Ellen has writing on the board,
one plus two plus three plus four
all the way up to 20 and I said,
and then they asked you a question like,
well what's all that out of two?
And a guy got up and said,
that's why I hate about this bath thing.
They ask you a town full question that
nobody could ask her and get right.
And even if they did, what would they
come out with? Some stupid number.
And we said right on, is that ever
right? Yeah. And then Ellen said,
if only there were a, a a nice way of
doing it, a beautiful way of doing it.
They said, I'll be out big
fat chance. I said, yeah,
if it's just some, you know,
different way of counting it,
voice over there,
you could do 10 bonds.
That's what water 10 bonds told
about new terminology. So you know,
one plus nine is 10 and and
three plus eight is 10 no,
you idiot says this guy to pesetas
10 so we get 10 bonds. Yeah,
we've gotten several,
well four or five 10 bonds,
then we've run out of 10 bonds. So it was
that we would make 20 bonds, you know,
one plus 19 said, no, we've already used
the one and the 10 votes. It's hopeless.
And they're getting,
they're getting a physically
quite restless and we're sweating.
And then a little guy at the back of the
room who hadn't said a word after that
point said,
I know this is wrong,
but which is always the preface to the
insight. He said, I know this is wrong,
but one plus 20 is 21 and so as
two plus 19 and as a sheer luck,
he said, no another voice. I said, no,
it's not sure a lot. They're all 20 ones.
Why? What do you mean they're all
20 ones? They're all, they're all,
all of them are 20 ones. Oh, what
if someone says all those numbers,
all those 20 numbers are 21 no,
says a voiceover here.
All those thingies are our
21 what do you mean thingies?
The thingies?
Someone says pairs.
All the pairs are 21 and I said,
how many pairs are there?
Someone says, they're a tet 210
high fives all around the room.
Can we do another? I said, yeah,
what's was Ellen said,
what's The sun from one to a hundred
it's a 5,050 give us another,
we did this for awhile. At the end
they said, what do you call this?
And we said math,
start with something which is below,
beneath the audience's dignity,
and then hit them with the mystery,
which turns out to be accessible,
and they are slaves to math for life.
[inaudible].